I was going to say I think we had talked
about you maybe doing a movie or
something that kind of covered the
bippin aspect of the bay yeah actually
my my partners in that the script is
done it's called uh it's called Splash
City they're coming here they'll
probably be here in like 30 minutes so
as soon as we're done with our interview
and tour then I'm going to sit down with
them review this script but that
script's ready um there's another script
ready as well so yeah just you know
takeing my time to [__] with it do right
yeah I feel like you know that is like
one of the things that like a so Bay
Area specific that when I talk to people
like they don't even they've never even
heard the word bipp and they're like
what the [__] is that like it's such so
they get here and they get their [__]
hit and I I feel like it's going to be
like the new school New Jersey Drive
almost in my opinion like it's going to
be dope because no one's really covering
the Bay Area and that's kind of my goal
I feel like all right I've made it to
the certain status I feel like I put on
hard with the music as as much as I
could and I'm going to still [__] with
it but I feel like my ultimate goal is
to kind of put the bay Oni back in the
sense of telling some of these stories
yeah tapping into some of this Untold
content like no one's ever attached to
the Bay like all the crime films and
movies are based on the York La Chicago
Boston you know like where's in Bay Area
stories at right and so I feel like I'm
trying to get into a position like
financially and you know just respect
wise where people will trust me with
those stories that'll be hard dude um I
haven't we haven't talked on camera
since you made the Forbes Magazine so I
just want to say congrats that should is
that [__] is pretty gnarly to like be
like damn my boy like my friend is on
the cover of Forbes like you know the
cool thing about that is like there's
people that are way richer than me and
there's people that that have built way
bigger businesses but to touch that
cover is like every businessman
entrepreneur's dream yeah so I have guys
like worth like hundreds of millions of
dollarars that H me like dog you did it
and I'm like bro you did it [__]
no you did it for real yeah you got it
got it right now liquid but I just think
it's a it's a really cool thing to come
out of cancer and then touch that cover
and then get the ad age award and get a
couple other things that we got like
it's just really cool and it's just good
U morale for like the kind of industry
I'm in I was going to say how does that
change your life being on that cover cuz
I'm sure it makes people look at you a
lot different two ways yeah no I mean
one people put more respect on the
business conversations but two everyone
thinks you just got it got it got it
like they just seen that word like $400
million they oh [__] you could
throw me give let me get half a mill let
me get let me borrow
like man like man invest this 2 m behind
my company I know you guys like bro like
yo like this this this valuation that
they're putting on me as a person um you
know kind of like relies on the
businesses performing executing and like
you know exiting one day right that's
what the value of my business is and so
kind of put a lot of things in
perspective you see even the rich rapper
list that [__] was trippy to me that
[__] is crazy cuz were you fourth or
fifth I was number four crazy and then
you put yourself next to rappers like um
[__] Dr Dre JayZ Dr Dre Jay-Z Kanye
know Diddy and like people like man
bur's not really rapper like wait a
minute hold up I do got 49 albums out
I've been rapping since 2006 people are
saying well he got businesses who so
does everyone else so everybody else
everybody else got you know uh at a time
to rock and and you know Rock Nation and
I mean yeah all kind of Ace of Spades
whatever you call it same it's the same
exact thing except the difference is I'm
Mexican and a [__] low-key Underdog
and so it's it's cool as [__] to see
that they recognize me on that list
because that list I always dreamed about
um about being on a list like that and I
always said that that that people are
overlooking what I built and I just just
remember one day kind of just throwing a
fit on Twitter like man I wish they
would look at my [__] and someone
actually was like well I'd be down the
audio and that's a really deep audit
they have to look at everything that you
have your assets your businesses it's
like a real they can't just put that
[__] out there to make the cash is it
the Cash Kings list is that what they
call it just the just uh Hip Hop's uh
you know wealthiest whatever it may be
um top five wealthiest you know so they
did that and yeah that [__] hit so they
like really like they turn over all the
pages and look into your [__] for real
for real yeah they do like a real audit
of you for sure oh wow so it ain't no
gazy ass number going out there no no
hell no no that's that's a real number
it's a real situation it's a real it's
just all around real like they're not
going to they're not going to play you
on that like they're not going to play
themselves it's real Publications with
real credible Riders and just you know
they're they're not play they're not
playing no games with that list that
list is very strategic it's very they do
a good job of due diligence you know I
had to have them talk to like business
managers and the people that do my taxes
and yeah that shit's real damn they're
like talking the CPA and all that [__]
CPAs they're looking at like properties
they're looking at the actual like are
you say your business worth this like
let's let's do actual audit of your
business do you know let's get a proper
what what did you raise at last time you
raised you know like it's it's real as
[__]